The bones in your body make up your skeleton.
You have 206 of them.
Bones give your body shape and support.
They keep the soft parts inside you safe.
Bones come in many shapes and sizes.
Your arms and legs are long bones.
Your pelvis and shoulder blades are flat bones.
The bones in your wrists, hands, ankles, and feet are small.
This is what your skeleton looks like.
Look at the many kinds of bones in your body.
Other animals have skeletons, too.
Each animal's skeleton is different.
Some are short, some are tall, some are light, and some are strong.
Look at this skeleton.
How is it different from your skeleton?
Do you know what it is?
CLUE: This animal flies.
It's an eagle.
Its bones are hollow and light.
Wing feathers attach to the wing bones.
Look at this skeleton.
How is it different from your skeleton?
Do you know what it is?
CLUE: This animal hops.
It's a frog.
It has long back legs for hopping.
Its back legs are longer than its body.